see nine all right we have a quorum
10 representative O'Brien is sitting in
for representative
lashman
and the first order of business is to
review and approve the minutes of the
previous meeting which have been
distributed are there any comments ments
or corrections to the
minutes okay see is there a
motion move the minutes second moved by
Senator gray second by Senator Bradley
all those in favor I I opposed all right
thank you uh we have the actuar cost
benefit analysis
from um the retirements
system that was uh emailed and put on
the website this
week so uh Mr Carlin would you care to
make some point out some highlights to
us I'm getting copies made for uh
um those who don't have them on their
uh and in fact there they
are I'll wait for those to
circulate all
right
okay so the specific question we asked
is on the last page Amendment uh
is this is yeah on the back page the the
additions have been highlighted in Gray
so starting with that one that's
Amendment 2259 s uh with the uh was um
we received an an analysis on back a
couple months ago but this variation
would only apply this change to um group
two tier B members who uh work to their
full age in service requirement Ms and
retire under service retirement so
vested deferred um non-job related
disability that type of thing it's so it
would shrink the pool somewhat from the
original 22 59s and that's the the
bottom uh row on the prior page page
three uh the difference the um in the
new
analysis the um the unfunded liability
impact went from 47 million to 43 9 and
the terminal funding cost went from 59.1
million to 53.7 million so that there
was
some
eliminating some members who weren't
going to be wouldn't aren't working to
full retirement age and going out on
service retirement reduce the cost of
The Proposal
somewhat uh the other um analysis was
related to um senator Gray's request uh
which would was to uh increase the
multiplier crw uh for every year work
past 20 years to two and a half% for
everyone in group two so that includes
tier b as well as tier c as well as
future members of group two so uh and
then the secondary question was what if
the change was only for tier B so those
are those are on page two the two gray
rows in the middle of that
um uh page show that the and and just
just as a refresher too under the
projected employer rate increase column
which is a column three there there's
different sets of numbers the the the
plus Point uh
xx% um numbers that represents the
percentage of pay increase projected
over current um or future uh employer
contributions um you know with no
funding with only the unfunded liability
funded and then if possible if there's a
terminal funding cost possible um that's
listed at the very bottom of that uh
item on that third column so for the
everyone in group two the Top gry Line
question one uh it's unfunded of 18.5
million um if that was funded the
increase um on the employer contribution
rate would be 31% of pay for police and3
for fire which equates out to about 1.7
million a year in
additional uh employer contributions
going forward beginning in fiscal
26 that proposal couldn't be estimated
for a terminal funding number because
it's it's open-ended it's there's you
know future hires who you know will just
keep coming in under the provision the
second question where it was limited
only to tier B this change the unfunded
was 11.6 million and because it's a
closed group uh they could look look at
a terminal funding number and that was
16.6
million thank you other
questions Mr
Carl thank you very much okay thank
you all right now that we have
a selection of options to um to consider
are there any that we wish to discuss
and recommend to the legislature Senator
Bradley you
have
so I think if you look
at the changes to Amendment uh 2259 on
the back of um this page and I think
hats off to Marty for doing a really
good job of keeping the information in
an understandable way I just want to
give him a shout out
um the
unfunded liability portion of
approximately $44 million I think is
getting into a
range
that we can
consider um we did this two years ago on
House Bill
um so we're me Senator it we did
something different in 1587 the same
amount of money yes correct okay so
that's my point um we're getting it into
a financial range that I think um offers
some opportunity for
consideration
the October numbers are um not out yet
but as of I think yesterday's summary
for Revenue we were about $17
million ahead for October that may
change slightly either way depending on
refunds or monies that came in on the
last day of the month
um
so I think we could pay for it um in
that range
of but it's still if you think of where
we are in terms of the Surplus with the
outstanding obligation and I keep
harping on this the YDC
settlement
um about 80 82% of the projected Surplus
as of now would be used for this purpose
so um I
think that gives me great caution to say
that so I will just say also in terms of
Senator Gray's proposal obviously um
significantly more affordable and has
the benefit of um actually doing
something for retention moving forward
so I I like the idea of um Senator
Gray's proposal a lot too and I like the
fact that it's far more affordable so
I'll stop there thank you madam chair
right Madam chair Senator Susie I
actually have a question for my
colleague Senator Bradley when you said
said the 80 million of surplus projected
you're not talking for the whole banian
you're talking about what was realized
so far I just want to clarify we are at
about $53 million of surplus right now
and so if we were to
allocate
43.9 million that's about 82% of them
right now of what we have currently okay
but you're talking what we have
currently okay I just wanted to make
sure I was clear thank you
Mr
camper um thank you madam chair um as
far as uh
2259 my concern is dividing uh this
middle tier up even further um would it
be possible
to take a look at um looking at the 2
and a half% multiplier for the those in
the the first five years and then um
seeing next session if we could look at
the 2 and a half% for um those in the
six to 10 year
range next session we can do whatever we
like there's no way we can can control
it so
uh if you think that we that if we adopt
one of these uh if we recommend one of
these plans we should also recommend
looking at further action in the next
session that's a a perfectly reasonable
recommendation but we can't guarantee
that it would
happen Mr real thank you madam chair
um I I Echo Mr campo's point about
further dividing uh this middle group
and I think it's problematic when you
look when you actually look at the what
the calculations would be um there are
members that had four years of service
prior to the changes in 2011 who had a
2.2 multiply
this bill here would give them a 2.25
multiplier uh while it is an increase
it's an increase of
05% uh in a year and um I would I would
have a a hard time advocating for that
as uh the only thing to come out of this
commission um I would like to see us get
to um the the full
2.5 for every member in the middle tier
um certainly if we had a a uh a way to
to pay for that upfront that is ideal um
but I would not advocate for a uh for
the the splitting of The Tib members in
this Bill thank
you all right the next question is does
someone wish to rec make a
recommendation that we propose one of
these
schemes to be for the legislature for
2024 Mr
real thank you madam chair uh I do not
have a recommendation but I was uh
hoping that we might be able to get some
further uh Clarity on the senator Gray's
first proposal and maybe Marty would be
able to help us with
that um I had a couple questions for him
if he's available
okay so this is the this would change
the multiplier to
2.5% for all group two
members including future
hires once they work at least 20 years
yes Mr Carlin thank you uh I was
wondering if in the GRS calculations if
they uh also were able to identify what
this benefit would look like if that 20
year mark was changed to 10 years or
some
other option uh no they just they just
did did the the analysis the specific
one that the commission endorsed so I'm
not sure what the impact of that would
be do you happen to know where they've
done a lot of this work already um would
that be somewhat of an easier
calculation to identify considering
they've done the majority of the work
um I I could check I know with the
original 2258 which was one of the first
pieces analyzed there was some follow-up
questions and JS was able to answer
those without doing the full scope
valuation so so you know was it was less
of a lift um I'm not sure how the model
works for this one so I'd have to I
don't want to speak for them I'd want to
reach out but I I could ask if the
committee would like
that I'd like to mention
that we are up against a
deadline the final report for this
commission is due December
1st and Halloween will take a actually
Halloween Halloween already took a big
chug Thanksgiving will take a chunk out
of
November and the Actuarial analysis have
been running two weeks
plus so we're we don't really have time
for a new
analysis or unless it's just a tweak of
an existing one yeah I I could ask the
question today probably have an answer
tomorrow if this is going to be a full
full scope it's going to take a couple
weeks or it's something that can be
answered before next Thursday as that's
I think that's what you were yeah next
next if we don't have an answer by next
Thursday it's going to be very difficult
to incorporate it and and the question
would be instead of ADD
any year after 20 years of service
you're you're you know and I know the
group would have to vote on it but what
what you put on the for discussion right
now is any year worked after 10 years is
two and a half per. correct yeah and
that is that for all groups or just tier
B that would apply to all groups as it
does in in this proposal and I would
just for clarity purposes those that are
um my intention would be those that are
already above that 10 year Mark those
years would also be calculated
in going
forward yeah it it wouldn't be
perspective to the date of the law if it
changes it's like these people aren't
retired yet so we can calculate you know
they somebody's got 12 years they've
already acred that and didn't know it
you know right okay okay Senator Bradley
so I would just make a suggestion if JS
is able to calculate it for 10 years I
think they could probably do it for 15
years years to just so that we are able
to
compare um Apples to
Apples okay well right I I can ask the
question and if it doesn't you know
require a full um valuation and they can
turn it around in a week I'll I'll alert
you to to let the committee know thank
you because either way just if it comes
in if it takes two and a half weeks
we're uh not going to be able to pay
much attention to it
okay centor de gr uh just a point of
clarification are we asking to do that
on the proposal that I made or the
proposal on page
four on The Proposal you made I believe
I that's just you know in yes Senator
gray on your proposal uh question one
that was added on uh
10:31 because I could certainly in
spirit of
compromise uh I could C certainly
support uh bringing that
percentage uh to
25 um earlier in their tenure uh if it
applies to Group
B uh because we've already done
something there um it becomes harder for
me to support it if I go back and do
tier C
also um but you know that's uh okay so
again that's just a new Nuance in in the
way I'm looking at this is you know I
I'm looking at trying to to help both
the tier B and the tier C people um and
to be able to do that and to keep the
cost
reasonable um I have to put some limits
on it so well thank you but we don't
know what the cost would be
correct Senator Bradley and that's
exactly why I suggested that if it's
going to get run it can get it should
get run for 15 years as well as 10 I I I
tend to agree with you yeah I I would
have been able to say that if you were
doing that to 2259 I think it would
require a full scope because there's
more moving Parts in 2259 because
there's also a reduction in the minimum
age in service and that proposal this is
just the multiplier with everything else
being equal so I I think the chances are
better of getting a a favorable answer
but again I I don't want to promise
until we get
to
any other comments all
right does anyone wish to move to
recommend a plan to the legislature we
have two at this point two ways to bring
a bring a plan to the legislature for
this coming year if we recommend
it we can include it in House Bill 436
which is retained in finance and if
approved by the committee that will go
to the Full
House in January and then go over to the
Senate so that if we make that
recommendation it could be adopted as
early as it could go into effect as
early as March L the governor
cooperating and the Senate
cooperating otherwise we can
recommend a different plan and bring
that in as a new bill we have the
authority as a statutory committee or
commission to bring in a bill outside of
the regular Bill filing period and
that's what we would have to do but that
would start brand new in January and it
would not be able to pass until June at
the
earliest Mr real have a question Madam
chair does that mean if the report is
due by December 1 does that I understand
it's last minute but does does that give
us the November 30th meeting to
potentially have a vote on this or does
that is that too
late that's later that I'm comfortable
with but if absolutely NE if we're
making progress we we could do it but
I'm would not want to plan on it could
we potentially try to hold off if we
don't have this Actuarial analysis until
the 16th to either the 9th or the 16th
to work on that vote
it's it's up to the commission when they
think they would be able to effectively
work uh the 16th is in my opinion
cutting it very close but it it could be
managed um I am not going to recommend
working meeting on the
23rd but the report is in fact due
December 1st so we have to
be um uh i' the 16th is probably the
last reasonable date for us to
meet Madam chair can I ask one more
question to Mr car while he's still here
please um if I recall when we originally
got the numbers on House Bill
436 the number of tier 2s was about
1,830 roughly and the new number this
Comm commission has been working with is
1731 could you tell me
when at what point you cut off to reach
the 1731 and what we can expect if it's
declining at a similar amount or if it's
actually accelerating really good
question Senator and and it it reminds
me I I I probably could have done it
when I introduced this grid back in you
know September to to do a little more
detail all of the actu an analysis
including the most recent is based on
the most recent rate setting valuation
which was
fy21 that's the
1824 count okay Ju Just because we had
the fiscal 22 numbers you know a year
sooner I put them on the chart those are
the you know but all all of the
estimates are based on that 1824 number
I did have you know you know we at nhrs
had a had a conversation with with some
of the actuaries about that and you know
this is this is sort of standard
practice for all analysis so it's you
know we just so it's Apples to Apples
sessional recession type of thing this
this is how we do this but it it's it's
fair to say that these costs are the
sort of the top end um if there are
fewer people affected by It ultimately
by the time it passes there is going to
be a decrease in the overall cost and
it's it's hard to put a percentage on if
you say oh it went from 1824 to 1730 31
that's five something because maybe a
math teacher here but you know it's it's
a percent but it's not that means this
is going to be 5% less because a lot of
it depends on the demographics of the
specific members who left were they the
newer people were they a year away and
they threw it in you know that all of
those things factor into it so it's it's
hard to sort of extrapolate it but it is
fair to say that these are sort of the
top end numbers and then it it could
only be less by some some degree if you
know there's fewer people by by the time
if something changes so if I could
follow up I just want to make sure I'm
understanding so it was the
1824 is what these numbers are based on
yeah but when they went on the chart
it's based on 1731 or 1731 is just the
current number I just want to make sure
yeah yeah no those are that last call
those are just the most recent numbers
they weren't used for actual real
analysis and we we kind of went back and
forth when we were setting up this grid
which number is better to give you
without causing confusion and that's
what we fell on and maybe we should have
stayed gone the other way but yeah no
it's not I I just wanted the explanation
because I just wanted to better
understand the cost implications so if
this is based on the
1824 and we know that within a year
we're down to 1731 I guess the question
is
then by this time next year would we be
looking at under 16
yeah and I I I do absolutely understand
it's dependent upon which member is it a
two-year member or a 19-year member yeah
and and this year this uh beginning in
February was the first year that anybody
in tier B was eligible to retire the
people who would have started you know
January very March of o2 I I so you may
lose some people to retirement already I
I I don't think you know there there
would would be a huge number especially
with everything pending people may want
to kind of write it out um but you know
there some some people either they could
have just terminated and went it's
invested the FR status or a few of them
may have retired and then obviously some
people may have been granted disability
benefits you know too so that's those
those are the pools of people who leave
people who get disabled or people who
can retire is what would be coming off
the list just if I could just one last
thing Madam chair um thank you so I
guess the numbers that are before us are
the absolute worst worst case scenario
the highest possible and we know there's
already been a decline from the numbers
that we're considering so we're actually
looking at something less we just can't
quantify how much at this point yes okay
thank
you anyone
else Senator Bradley you have a comment
a
recommendation
okay anyone
else represent Packard thank you madam
chair I'm not going to propose a
recommendation now but I'm just going
to mildly insist that whatever we do
recommend and whenever we do come up
that this is it let's fix this thing
once and for all and move on I do not
want to have to come back here next year
and the year after and the year after uh
trying to fix this thing again and again
and again so I would just implore the
members of this commission that whatever
we do vote on we vote on it and that
this will fix this thing once and for
all thank
you representative
O'Brien thank you uh Madam chair uh I
couldn't agree more than what what
speaker just said uh it seems the
intention by Mr Colin will expedite the
process as best as he can if
allowed and I think patience is a
virtue and I think if the committee
members had the full complete
understanding of what uh uh Mr will
suggests I think we'll be able to come
up with something if we live in debate
limited to discussion to the proposal
and see if that can fly and then I think
we could do it at that particular
date so I would urge I I know you're not
pleased but I hate to delay it too but
again I have to agree with the speaker I
mean we've been fixing this for an awful
long time so
okay if that is the intention
then we need to
know um whether we can get that those
numbers in a in a reasonable period of
time and we would need to meet at least
once
more yep okay everyone understands that
I would just yes say Madam chair I'm not
available on the 16th so hopefully the
ninth will work nor am I that you're not
available on the 16 all right well and I
will be out of
state we'll we so fine then Mr Carlin
your charge is to let let me know as
soon as possible if there is a chance of
getting those numbers in time for a
meeting on the
9th Absolutely I'll soon as I soon as I
get to a keyboard I'll I'll start typing
that email out okay and we
will assuming that that happens we will
meet plan to meet on the
9th whether or not we have the numbers
because we've got to come to some final
conclusion and it looks like the 16th is
not going to be a useful day is that
agreeable all right so we'll meet on the
16th we will have some numbers we hope
the nth the ninth sorry thank you so
much for keeping me on my
toes all right is there anything else we
need to discuss
today oh yes Senator
greay are we going to take any action on
any cost of living thing um certainly I
put out the proposal that uh we rewrite
the legislation if it's needed to allow
uh the employers of uh group one and
group two to uh to do matching because
when I suggested that they told me to
allow it it would would take
legislation um I don't believe that we
that it is necessary for employers other
than the
state I mean they can do whatever that
as far as I know they can do almost
anything that they they like is part of
a negotiated contract I see the
association of counties agrees with me
thank you Miss
Stacy um so it's only for state
workers
okay so what would you propose that um
again as a a way to uh allow both group
one and group two people uh to be able
to utilize that and have a state match
uh that uh I would like to see you know
out of this commission that the
recommendation that legislation be
brought forward uh that would allow that
to be negotiated uh with the unions and
then the appropriate
um uh recommendation for for people who
are not in the union to to uh to get the
same benefit as those people in
similar circumstances I'll second
that okay thank you Mr
R uh question for Senator gray if he's
willing um are you proposing that
everyone in the retirement system would
get a state match to their 457 whether
they're state employees or not what I'm
saying what originally when I
investigated this I believe that the
answer came back and that said that they
needed um legislation to allow it okay
um the chair has said that and the
county uh Society hasn't uh hasn't
agreed with that that it would only be
the state employees that I would need to
be able to do that with uh but again it
would be a negotiated benefit so if
you're representing the firefighters or
the police or the state police or
whatever uh that would be a negotiated
benef benefit along with your um salary
uh that you negotiate and that would
come through a a different uh Financial
structure than the retirement system and
therefore uh that would be the
negotiated cost
so I respect I respectfully withdraw my
second I was outside the retirement
system I just heard that I'm sorry I you
understand it first so in favor yes Mr
Ro um if I could just speak to that I uh
I'm I'm fearful here that we're getting
into a place where we're uh as a
commission trying to establish um a
benefit that's not truly a benefit it
already it already exists we've multiple
people have testified to the fact that
this is already being negotiated now um
there are cities and towns that already
have this negotiated now if we're
talking about doing it for from the
state doing it a matching for the state
employees then that's a different or
it's part of the same conversation but
it's not um it it doesn't sound like
that's what's being proposed at the
moment senator may I reward your motion
to say that we
recommend
all all
employees
negotiate
a re
a a benit benefit outside of the
retirement system matched by their
employer to fund colas and that we
submit legislation that would authorize
that to be done for state
employees we we recommend the same thing
for all workers but only the state
employees need specific legislation to
authorize
it um does that meet your intent for
what you said Madam chair that is uh
what I would propose
right and I'll second it as that point
is any other
discussion Mr Fuller and then Mr Martine
yes well at the same time I know it's
it's related to this but earlier I
proposed actually a traditional Cola
that's actually funded by the retirement
system so I understand that's not part
of the motion but just as I mean that's
something where I would like to see us
more go in that direction instead of it
being indir you know then it's not it's
it's a much more Equitable system
instead of just have it being
individually done by cities and towns
that way some gets a benefit and some
doesn't get the benefit it's much more
clean that way in my opinion all right
Mr martinz I will Echo that I think that
a Col within the retirement system is a
lot clearer easier to manage and and
manage and and uh
work because we already can do anything
outside so here we're talking about New
Hampshire retirement system we did had a
Col account that we closed 1983 we moved
the total probably $600 million doll out
of it so we should return to what was
always meant to be a defined benefit
Coler in the retirement system workers
have been paying 2% extra since 2011
maybe we can entertain assign 1% of that
to fund e Cola it would be a slight dial
down on the payment of the unfunded
liability but it would be something that
we can start propos this for the for the
future I know we cannot fix everything
here today but we can have ideas and
explore that I think the col Retirement
System in summary is the best way to go
we all as we had it thank you all right
any other M sty yes so thank you madam
chair so I can tell you that we're going
to oppose that um I think we need to be
very cautious of what we're doing I know
that in the past a couple years ago we
did do a cola and the state funded it
when you're looking at colas you're
looking at the employer having having to
come up with that money unless you're
saying you're going to be using what's
already the employees doing but if the
you cannot continue to put the onus on
the employers to come up with these
colas I mean I've been in the system for
30 years I wasn't told I'm going to get
colas when I retire that wasn't one of
the bargains it was a defined benefit
which is based upon what I put in and
and is matched thank you madam chair
Mary yes Mr Martine thank you uh
a cola benefit is not a luxury it's in
the same line of payments benefit raises
inflation adjustment that's what a coal
is it's not something out of the planet
that we we say oh we can't afford to do
this we have to find ways to afford it
because you know that's a person works
for an employer that's how we get
paid we never intended to have a benefit
that washes away with inflation
otherwise you reti if you live live long
you're going to have zero in the end
that was never the plan it was never the
way it worked it was never the way it
worked we always had the col benefit so
it's not something extraordinary you
have to remember we had that all the way
to 2011 when was removed from the legisl
so we do have that it's not
extraordinary it's a normal and part of
the retirement system thank you
okay representative
Brian thank you madam chair um in case
some of you do know or don't know
uh the other hat or helmet that I wear
is I'm also on the uh the board of
alderman for the city of
nashille and I can speak wholly for what
nashille has gone through because the
changes in the state pension system
hasn't increased the city's budget $2
million and to me the thing that needs
to get fixed was the previous item that
was discussed that in itself could have
some cost Savings in the
municipalities because that $2 million
equal 1% of the nashal tax rate okay
now the state has always
had
cers okay as far as you know being a
member of the uh
nhrs they were given out from time to
time I think it's something that needs
to be disc discuss but try to combine it
into this committee into one thing I
think we're getting towards the end with
the December 1st deadline and I think we
would be best to just to focus on fixing
the problem because it does revert back
to the local taxpayers if we can get
this item fixed so I shared a thought
with Cola but I think the duty of future
legislation can probably with time
equally conquered it thank
you anyone
else
Senator so slightly different take on
this
um there was a cola that was authorized
in
2019 um Governor sonunu signed it in a
law the cost for
employers um I believe exceeded a
hundred million so that's County Schools
State and cities and towns so colas are
expensive there's no question about that
on the other hand they are an incentive
and retention tool so they have some
Merit but they have to be paid for and
my view is that if we're going to
Institute a cola it should be a shared
responsibility by employers and
employees that everybody sees the
benefit of it and everybody shares the
cost
and I don't think that there's any way
that we could be ready for a
recommendation on December 1st but what
you Madame chair might want to consider
is asking all of the employer
Representatives on this commission and
all of the
um labor Representatives on this
commission to form a subcommittee
and negotiate and see if there is some
mutual um consensus that would fit
within those terms of a shared
responsibility by employers and
employees it it would be something over
and above um Mr martine's in my view of
what would be appropriate what employees
already pay and employers would have to
absorb some additional cost but it would
it would have to be seen as a shared
benefit and I think that could be a I
can't remember if this commission
dissolves or not maybe somebody else
knows but there's no reason why even if
the commission dissolves that the folks
that are sitting at this
table management and labor so to speak
can't try to negotiate that and come
back to us in the legislature if there
is something that's a win-win for
everybody and then we could consider it
and it could be a late filing and once a
late Bill comes in GRS can analyze it
for cost that we have you know more data
to go on than you know just is a cola
good is a cola expensive is a cola
worthwhile we can go on and on and on
with that debate it's going to take him
employers and employees in my view to
agree to
something thank you Senator that's
absolutely true but there
are what 200 300 Employers in the
retirement
system the only one we have direct
control over is the is the state
employees you and I as members of the
legislature give put the limit on what
can be negotiated with the the state
employees uh we have no very little
control over what the teachers negotiate
withu 53 for example it's it's we don't
have much control over that or what the
the point I'm trying to make is if
there's consensus and maybe there won't
be maybe this is an exercise in futility
I don't know but until you try um if
there's a consensus among the various um
management entities and obviously the
state has to be part of that but also
the entities representing all of the
labor groups then then it becomes
something that could come in front of us
could have a a real analysis for the
cost and
then
decide whether to move forward with it
but I also realize that it's November 3D
and if we're trying to have a report
which we need to have by December 1st
that's difficult but there's no reason
that those discussions can't continue to
occur if people on both sides want them
to very
true um Mr
Speaker I think the um Senate President
and I could make this commission
continue if we wish to and um I uh am
uncomfortable voting on anything today
that has to do with something we don't
have figures on we don't know how it's
going to work and we don't know how it's
going to affect everything so I think if
that discussion wants to continue that
it would be prudent to do so but not
under the circumstances where are today
let's fix this problem that we started
out with and then let's continue the
discussion on the uh um you know the
colas or whatever else that they needs
to be discussed but let's let's fix what
we got to fix at
first well Senator gr that sounds like
you and I are the only ones in favor of
your
proposal Madam chair certainly the
proposal that I made uh would not
exclude any Cola thing that you were
doing um it would be an added way that
that uh departments when they
negotiating with their unions could do
this um would not have any long-term
effects on on
colas U certainly I know that when I
retired at least once you know they came
to me and told me how I could split my
money up and you know buy annuities and
not buy annuities Etc uh this would uh
the proposal that that I made would uh
uh let them have a pot of moneyy should
they choose to make those
contributions uh that they could use and
manage that money um any way they choose
uh chose to do it U so uh I I would like
to see an up or down vote on it and fine
and and okay then at least I can tell
them I tried okay so there's a a motion
that the commission
recommend
that all employees and employers
fund a
negotiated way for to provide cost to
living
increases and that we submit legislation
to allow that to happen with the state
as the employe correct there a point of
inquiry yes would that be through the
New Hampshire retirement system the
payments and disbursement no no probably
not it would have to be negotiated one
way or the other but it would be between
each employer and each employee
group Senator question Madam chair I'm
just trying to understand so are you
saying this would be a mandatory subject
of bargaining I mean I I I don't know
that the proposal I don't know that I
personally feel comfortable enough to
vote on The Proposal
without more precise language before us
because I I think we could be going a
field of what is I think good intent but
just the way that it was explained to me
is that there would have to be enabling
legislation to allow for state
employees so you know when the when the
drafting happened and it'll get a full
hearing of both the the the Senate and
the house you know should it actually be
reduced to a bill and uh some of those
details I think Senator would be be
worked out at that time Senator the
problem is that the recommendation would
apply to all government employees in the
state and the legislation would only
apply to those actually employed by the
state government so the recommendation
is that
each municipality or School District or
whatever would negotiate with its
employees to find a way to fund a cost
of living increase and that we would
have enabling legislation so that the
state employees could do the
same um I wouldn't put cost of L into it
I would call it an employee match which
which is what it is and it's called you
know in other and that
uh you know that again what I was told
is that we needed enabling legislation
that says you know
you're allowed to do it
so Mr
R thank you madam chair I would ask that
if our plan is to come back on the
9th um I would request that we have this
proposal reduced to writing like we've
been required to do for previous
proposals before we vote on it if I'm
not I'm not opposed to having that
conversation I just I want to make sure
that we're clear on what we're voting on
be happy to all right thank you so our
we will not vote on that today we
Senator gray will provide a mo a motion
in writing so that we will know what
we're voting on all right is there any
other business we need to discuss today
knowing that we're coming back in a we
in uh in a
week okay being none we are
adjourned